you all right no yeah you don't look  okay dude I didn't it's not even that I  did anything get home at midnight me be  me I'm hungry which have like a little  peanut butter sandwich throw a little  milk Down the Hatch just to you know  okay 15 minutes later I'm like oh knife  is going through my stomach I'm thinking  what the hell I'm [ __ ] water like  actual water not milk no I would assume  it would be milk that you'd be [ __ ] no  it's like my stomach kept all the dairy  and then squeezed out  it Juiced yeah it Juiced the milk  blew my back out when I stood up my legs  were all numb I was trying to get back  to bed I'm just like  this guy named milk just blew my ass out  nothing you got your world raw just blew  my ass out man